so I heard a lot that the summer
seasonal video I did last year lacked a
lot of substance so here it is this is
what you want people the time you've all
been waiting for the anime you all want
me to talk about look look at it it's
it's a it's it's a [ __ ] cat in a
banana how would you not love this hey
guys its kia kia and it's the start of
the summer season and that means it's
time for every anime reviewers crawl out
of their little hole and watch all the
[ __ ] so you don't have to so if you're
watching this I'm guessing you're either
here to get a feel for the season figure
out what's worth watching or just find
out a little more information about
certain shows but here's a little help
to you anyway I'm either watching
dropping or giving the show 3 episodes
which you can see in this tiny little
corner here you may not agree with me
but hey that's just my opinion man okay
see we start things off with a calming
light-hearted slice-of-life anime about
oh oh god what is wrong with your face
is it safe to be looking at her like
this still waiting for the kick to
happen it's probably wondering when yeah
I wasn't sold in this one I mean having
a football animes nice and all but as a
fan when I'm seeing someone who can't
run can't kick the ball and is
essentially the shinji ikari of football
it looks really [ __ ] stupid to me
when a bloke almost cracks his head open
and everyone's just like well so let's
not forget the very obvious oh oh wait
here it comes here here it comes you
know you know it's gonna come is kicking
me any second now it's getting closer
it's coming sees coming it's coming wet
patches and let's start writing some
fanfiction but tell me what happens if
you take days and multiply it by 91 you
get 91 days hahaha okay that was
horrible I should kill myself but this
anime on the other hand is looking
pretty [ __ ] good I mean we have an
Italian mafia story set in a Prohibition
era and it looks so [ __ ] legit the
opening credit was done in English like
a proper gangster film and I gave me
such a big fat hard-on I didn't even
know why I mean it's just wise flashing
up on screen but [ __ ] look it just
looks really [ __ ] cool Hey look it's
zero hey look it's a real life hey look
it's a rewrite hey look it's a reason to
[ __ ] kill myself whoa whoa calm down
it's just a joke just a joke bro I'm
sorry I just don't know why love life
needs another [ __ ] season I'm sorry
I'm sorry what the [ __ ] is she talking
about if you could send messages to
alter the past what would you do with
such unprecedented power would you warn
the word about Hitler save JFK prevent
9/11 now that's [ __ ] stupid and not
gonna actually do any good what's really
important in life is that you give that
guy that lunch you made for him that one
day instead of being a [ __ ] and
pussying out so continuing on from the
trend that every season this year needs
at least one time-travel anime Orin just
looking promising as a shoujo series
with a small time travel element but a
shape not to hit you right in the fields
but speaking of time-travel shoujo anime
time-travel shoujo anime I just I just
really wanted to use that segue but
seriously you know that one anime every
season when you were just like wow only
in anime
well Japanese high school girl travels
back in time to meet Benjamin Franklin
Thomas Edison and other inventors and
have a whale of a time yeah and here
comes our totally generic action anime
concept that has some kickass action
animation all right I'll give you a
chance as long as you keep giving her
more milk if you know what I'm saying
she's a cat it's it's its cat she's a
cat cats like milk see now this is a
concept that I totally understand how it
came to be Hey
what do you talk who's like cute girls
in the video game industry so what
happens if we make ski girls and the
video game industry well then I'm gonna
hold a funeral for my erection now is
this no this isn't is this
is this Chinese cartoons and now time
for my totally accurate impression of
each sequel this season didn't watch
didn't watch didn't watch
why the [ __ ] are there two didn't watch
but we've somehow made JoJo's even
[ __ ] weirder but if somehow made
JoJo's even [ __ ] weirder so we got
mob cycle 100 which takes place in salt
middle school wait wait that doesn't
seem right I think there's a
mistranslation there there we go man
there's just so much salt being thrown
around this show this just this is too
[ __ ] easy hey guys guys so what arts
online was pretty good vicen balls
season 3 never Coke and Pepsi taste the
same but in all seriousness it seems
pretty bloody cool a bones anime
adapting a webcomic from the same guy he
made one punch man and you know just see
we interrupt this video to bring you a
message from crunchyroll
that was a message from crunchyroll
Thanks crunchyroll but I don't think you
need so many sponsorships to get people
excited about mob psycho I mean this
this is pretty [ __ ] awesome and
everyone can tell I mean no I just I
just I just said you don't need to pay
me to say that no not me no let's not
stop it
hey looks for me bizarre content wait is
is this a game I mean the graphics look
a bit dated but where can I get this
game what the what where the hell is
this game I got I can't find it at all
is this the game I'm looking for is this
the game I'm looking for is this the
game I'm looking for way is is this is
this a new [ __ ] berserk at all god
it's a new [ __ ] berserk anime I mean
is it too much to ask for a
decent-looking berserk anime that can
actually hold a candle to cantar ramírez
amazing art I mean who in their right
mind thought that this was an acceptable
professional production to one of the
greatest manga of all time you think I'm
overreacting you think there's no way
anime can let you down so horribly well
let's just see what the rest of the
world think about this boom Isis claims
responsibility for horrific berserk
animation so we all know Batman and
Superman was pretty bad but what do you
guys think of new berserk animation well
the interesting thing is that we get
dude a hip hip caucus Gaston I'm sorry
to say all our sacrifices were in vain
because this is what the ban on the
whole [ __ ] died for all right let's
take a break from all this and load up a
game that actually exists whoa
oh man the graphics and this is
absolutely amazing okay look at this it
looks beautiful and holy [ __ ] the battle
mechanics looks so smooth and pretty
enough oh wow oh this is just the anime
so as usual you fordable can make
something look absolutely breathtaking
but as someone who's already played the
game if the story and characters stays
faithful to it then yeah don't expect to
be blown away or anything but hey at
least it looks pretty right right and a
large show is this sweetness and light
thing and I mean it looks cool it's cute
the kid seems a bit adorable but you
know me cute things alone don't always
do it for me so I guess I'll just give
this apart this smile I will protect
this smile I will fight you for this
smile you will not hurt this smile for
you see there are some things in life
worth protecting some things worth
living for some things worth dying for a
smile like this can throw the iciest of
hearts dispel the darkest of Evil's and
win the mightiest of wars this smile
will be the thing that pulls us from a
depth of despair and lead us to the path
of salvation Wars will be fought people
will be saved and civilizations will
prosper because of this smile so from
this day forward I suddenly swear to
shield this smile from all harm that may
come to it all dangers it may possibly
face and give my life for it it needs
yeah I'm watching this anime
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video
special thanks to Vincent Mooney flash
anime Lau Ken Moretti Roy Havey and
everyone else you support me on patreon
to make this possible
so apparently um during seasonal videos
now how original right if anything
caught your eyes some of them are
available and crunch wall so you can
also go to cruncher Otacon slash the
anime zone for a free month of premium
membership but that's it for me today no
real updates I'm actually going back to
England I'm actually going back to
England in two days so sorry if the next
video is a few days late
because I'll be setting myself back up
in England but anyway that's it I've
been gig up until then I'll see you all
next time